you
let's roll let's go here I'm gonna get
you good here let's roll man live chess
is back on live okay hmm you haven't
seen the last of me here actually it's
not the longest dream of our my key in
the twitch chat the longest one is 16
straight hours I'm a special occasion I
just did that from time to time okay
what's the plan here it's not the type
of opening you really want to play let's
try this one not against the computer at
least I have something in mind
mmm let's try this get a grip over d5 ok
bishop in maybe I should have prevented
that all right it's not going with it
it's usually useful move pawn to h3 and
I want to get my bishop developed so
let's guard be too yeah figured you
would do that I figured this much
huh hi there's an opportunity here to
get rid of both tricky nights huh and
what I mean is Knight takes Knight pawn
takes Knight d 5 i'm not sure how i
should recapture in that position
actually maybe i am like this as
otherwise this rook is very active
Knight takes pawn takes here or Knight
takes pawn takes here I don't even know
what that would do ooh you know what I'm
gonna go for this and then try and pick
up this pawn let's see to do this with
Bishop b2
hmm
Bishop here this night has to move can't
be comfortable wherever he goes ah you
know what I thought that this wasn't
good ok I want to do this but there's
gonna be a knight takes no that's not
working is thinking night takes I have
to do this and then there'd be a pawn
push with check but I could play f4
maybe there's no rush with that if i
play F for Queen 85 it usually goes pawn
hunting although I could play just a
four lockdown on b5 it may be able to be
too stupid to realize that a six and b5
would be a good idea I already have the
square covered so I'd have to worry
about you know my III square so ol as
soon as I do this I think I should run
with it right away maybe I should
however wait and play Queen d2 yeah let
me do Queen d2 i'm doing this so that i
don't oh well the bishop could still
play there when i do this i was silly oh
well
well it's fun with that I guess Bishop
here is gonna be played no it's not
interesting I could capture Oh
I like capturing just have the open file
Bishop here with Queen here Bishop here
this hmm how do I get my night working i
want my night on this square it's not
easily done though King here if h 4g for
Bishop takes pawn takes Knight takes
with check followed by 93 is very
annoying so I don't want to do this
common natural King h2 how can i get my
night working maybe b4 b5 let's try that
so the majority over here I don't want
to go see 5 just yet because then
there's this b6 break okay it's doing
nothing moves now I'd like to relocate
my bishop let's go here no let's go here
first I don't want to lose control this
diagonal so easily ah what a bug okay
let's do this and then get my bishop
here okay it's getting out of that
hmm maybe now that this Bishop isn't
here I could do this like g1 f3 here
let's try it g1 f3 he had setting that
up let's do this though Bishop to d2 if
the night comes here gotta start going
quicker 21 seconds nights in a pin go
here and defend the Bishop Knight g4 was
a threat ok let me relocate my night
let's just defend that ok I feel like
it's going alright let me get my king
back out of there out of those night
checks it's a very uncomfortable pin
that black is in well they're in two
pins I'm gonna win this game I can feel
it feel it doubled rooks or double
trouble oh I'm less than 10 seconds
though
hmm I need to maybe triple up let's get
back over here
alkynes gun I should have they got out
of the pin get rid of the dark square
Bishop get my night back onto this g5
square ok it's offering a draw I don't
want to draw I want my night on G oh are
you kidding me these cheap tricks let me
do that now that wasn't a good idea ah
figures it would do this much
yeah I've clearly lost control now
clearly yeah it's gonna go pawn hunting
now for sure pawn hunting there goes
another one ah I lost control what a
tactic man cheap tactic oh man
you